alors vous donc gynéco parce que vous
avez des enfants exact trois enfants et
ils ont quel âge alors 20 21 22 je pense
aussi les frères ouais merci et il te
demander comment on faisait les enfants
n'ont en fait ils sont assez il sera
c'est sûr là c'est physique j'ai une
éducation à ces simples particulière je
laisse les enfants parce qu'ils ont une
très belle réponse je vous demandais
comment oser les enfants avec des poules
ils ont faim vous lui diriez comment est
bien avec le team soum il ya et c'est un
mystère personne le sait on ne sait pas
comment la terre a été faite ni comment
les enfants arrivent sur un mystère et
10 rebonds
comment on fait les bébés c'est une
bonne question et vas-y
j'ai demandé à ma femme parce que c'est
mieux que moi si le papa qui la dépose
la graine il a un petit secret
là vous ne vont pas comment elle remonte
la crème
mais facility va pas qui a le secret ne
pour poser la fédé si tu veux on
s'embrasse on a nos corps qui se
touchent n'est ce pas le sexe de
monsieur et le nez dans le sexe de la
dame
c'est très envisageable des jeux même
qu'il irait non si ceux ci s'avèrent
chaise qui fait monsieur ça arrive de
petites graines bas il s'agit c'est un
peu on va demander aux médecins qu'est
ce que doit prêts pour les parents quand
on leur dit commencer les enfants je
pense qu a pas de bonne réponse à l'us
la brède
écoutez je pense qu'il n'ya pas de bonne
réponse et de mauvaises vrai nom mais on
peut exprimer axa sensible où il irait
alors vous savez j'ai un enfant de 5 ans
et demi et c'est avec un petit point
quand il va vous demander
ben je lui dis c'est très compliqué ce
que je suis pas très à l'aise sur ce
genre de sujet donc indépendants qui
peuvent très à l'aise expliqué de façon
un peu plus cru mais dire qu'une petite
graine dans le ventre de la maman
pourquoi pas expliqué que c'est un
mystère pourquoi pas expliqué que c'est
une cigogne
peu importe parce que comme je le dis
finalement ils vont l'apprendre figure
mais le porte encore en fonction des
enfants si la 4 en 3 ans a peut être mis
en fonction de finalement c'est très
bien qu'un jour ou l'autre ils vont
tomber sur internet et qu'un qui vont le
savoir doit sûr mais dont il dit ne vous
dit rien moi je dirais la petite graine
dans le ventre de la maman elle est
naïve je me rappelle à lui a dit elle a
dit c'est la graine de couscous dans le
bouillon alors mal hein c'est loupé
abandon ne veux qu'ils aient dit quoi
jeudi les garçons naissent dans les
choux et les gars sont dans les choux et
les filles se finisse dans les choux moi
je vous jure que c'est une histoire
vraie ce qu'est l'histoire dromer de sa
médiation à 21h vous êtes sur un gamin
qui a une soirée vient voir son papa et
lui dit c'est quoi l'histoire de la
petite graine est le monsieur lui dit
pas c'est quand on met dans maman me
papa mais la petite graine et le gamin
lui dit devant 15 personnes mais alors
qu'est-ce qui fait avec sa [ __ ] après
un ange qui décide de passer sébastien
[Rires]
trives plutôt un jeune maxime et que
c'est vite après dix finales
génial